well guys have been watching Hugh Grant
movies hello and welcome to trigonometry
I'm Frances Foster i'm konstantine
kisses and this is a show for you if
you're bored with people arguing on the
internet over subjects they know nothing
about trigonometry we don't pretend to
be the experts we ask the experts
our brilliant guest this week is a
leading female dating and attraction
expert for men Kezia Noble welcome to
trigonometry hi thank you for having me
it is great to have you here and before
we get into the meat of the interview
tell us a little bit about who are you
how are you where you are how do you
find yourself sitting in this chair
telling us all about where you're gonna
tell us about well as you said I'm a
leading female dating and attraction
expert for men I only help men don't
help women because that would be the
blind leading the blind I've been doing
this since 2006 I have my own company my
own team I have I think 30 people
working for me they're based in Britain
and the u.s. I run courses 7-day mastery
programs and I have my online training
programs too I'm a published author I
have a YouTube channel that's had 70
million views oh I know I didn't get the
silver the thing that they send through
you get a hundred thousand subscribers
you know I get that no I didn't I'm four
hundred and something thousand so I
thought I was gonna get something like
the gold you get the gold you hear a
million right and yeah that's my life in
a nutshell do you get demonetized on
youtube yes really yes you get to
monitor yeah for some videos yeah for
what how they get a girl into bed
superfast that one didn't you know he
didn't like that one alright but someone
they were really random like how to not
run out of things to say with a woman
what do you monetize
I know random no that's horrific
boring conversation yeah yeah yeah
so I was watching one of your videos I
think it was about something to do with
how to compliment a woman oh yeah and
you were talking about the fact that
just saying something like oh you look
lovely or whatever is not is [ __ ]
because it does not communicate your
real intent right you were saying you
need to make it more sexy so okay well I
was going to quote you a specific
example you know but correct me hmm okay
so if you okay there's there's two types
of compliments so there's one which is
you have to make the compliment feel
very detailed with the spoke that
doesn't necessarily mean that you have
to sex it up so you could say something
like oh my god you're adorable I could
you know like a Disney I don't know
princess or something I can't put my
finger on it it just shows that it's a
little bit tailor-made for her and it's
a little bit of thought I love the way
that you know you put your outfit
together for instance I love the fact
that you know how to do makeup so many
girls don't have a clue about how to put
on makeup it's specific it means you've
noticed something about her that she's
put some effort in hmm is that detail if
you say lovely beautiful attractive it's
generic it could you could say that to
the next girl and she knows that but
something specific always what we found
creates a better reaction sure now the
part when you 6 that that's if you're
like in that nice guy zone so you were
talking about this and you were talking
you you're sitting down with some with
you're a man you're sitting down with
the woman that you're having a
conversation everything's going well you
need to take it to you need to sex it up
you need to take to the next level and
the example that was given in that video
was like I think your legs are very sexy
or something a lot a compliment about
her legs yeah your legs look hot your
legs look hot right now I am NOT on the
dating scene but I know a lot of people
just in the look of rasa's his face like
in our world right it's certainly among
comedians or whatever if you went out
for a drink with the female comedian and
you were do you thought you were getting
on and then
you made that I mean that could
literally kill your career permanently
right then don't go out with somebody
oh I wouldn't use that maybe somebody
that you're gonna see again and again
and again but at some point I mean you
are gonna have to escalate it so if
you're not gonna do it verbally then you
have to do it physically you're gonna
have to go for the kiss at some point
yeah right yeah so some people would be
like well I'm gonna test the water hmm
and see you know say this this just
rewind this for a second hmm if a woman
is attracted to a guy and he toes
arouses your legs are [ __ ] hot she's
she's gonna like it yes she might say oh
that's a bit cheeky yeah but she's gonna
like she's gonna like it if she doesn't
fancy that though she's not gonna like
it so it's your way of testing the water
so if she's like mmm like that but
uncomfortable after you said something
like that you're like I'm not backing
down you've got beautiful legs you don't
back down but then you can know okay
she's not that interested right now if
she just kind of goes really do you
think they know they're all for my legs
cause to me she carries ooh wanting to
talk about it
that's a good sign so I'll give you some
what if a guy and I've had guys I've put
in the friend zone and they're like
trying to get out the friends and I'll
be like okay here why you look so hot
and I'll be like thanks nothing about
your friend zone shut it down like okay
thank you so cute Thanks so adorable
shut down don't bring up any more if
it's a guy like I might oh really you
think so or on midians secure about my
legs
it's meaning can you can you validate me
a little bit more can I hear this a
little bit more because it's the way
we're talking about it and you were
saying that a lot of your fan base is
actually based in America I imagine with
some British guys isn't this
excruciating ly difficult going
complement her and because we're so
bound as British people you just can't
even express ourselves emotionally more
difficult yeah and plus we've been well
guys I've been watching Hugh Grant
movies any when Hugh got does it in that
those movies they don't women did not
fancy that kind of guy and I see showing
like other elements you
you can be like this really good guys a
lot of people think I'm trying to teach
guys to be the bad guy that's another
common mistake people make but I'm
teaching guys to just show that they're
not one-dimensional nice guys like I've
been on dates of with men my ex-husband
for example and he was like very perfect
you know I just came from a good family
he was really polite and just treated me
like a lady and I enjoyed it but I was
like something's missing
I don't know what it is something's
missing maybe I like bad guys maybe I'm
just one of those women I just got to
end up with some oh okay and we were
having dinner and I was about to tell
him look you're a really nice guy but
there's just no chemistry and he leaned
in and I thought he was just gonna like
say something like pass me something
he's like oh you know I can't wait to
[ __ ] you something like this really but
he was like totally unapologetic about
him can you pass me the red wine that
was the missing piece you've got to be
bold and show that other side to you
otherwise the girls just gonna be like
yeah it's just another nice guy that I
can't see anything happening with you
know because it's um oh but fortune
favors the bold right yeah absolutely
and favor support I just can't imagine a
lot of British guys doing that like you
say that I can imagine American guy like
you know I can imagine a latino guy yeah
I mean they'd say that after 50 seconds
but I can't imagine a British guy saying
that and delivering those words
comfortably unless they were absolutely
battered I've experienced this the
British guys it's less so British guys
always think they're mmm baby yeah
they're not so good with women and I
they've got the banter which is good
they got the banter they got the humor
[Music]
yeah when it comes to sexual escalation
there is an insecurity there there is
that hesitancy I've noticed and so she
wants to ask you questions yeah I don't
know like the whole
story with your how you got with your
partners I go how we met but there's got
to be this point where you first kissed
yeah now okay this is I know this is
gonna be like a little bit private but
you have your first case where you
plastered were you drunk no so I'm sober
there we go and most of the time yeah
and no I met my girlfriend doing comedy
so I ran a gig and she was just starting
out doing comedy went to the spot she
wanted something I needed some things
change
it's absolutely blessed and then I was
up at the Edinburgh Festival and so if
she wanted another spot again this
doesn't mean this is a slow burn
yeah exactly says Frances ruining yeah
well you have leavin anyway believe I'm
telling this story yourself great okay
so we're at the Edinburgh Festival and
then I said would you like to go for a
drink and she went yes and then she
brought her friend along with her that's
a bad sign yeah so then I brought my
friend along and we ended up having a
really sort of awkward conversation we
then carried on to a bar and she bought
me a shot and and we saw so I could go
and have the shot I've been about eight
months sober by this point I had the
shot we we then got on great guns she
went home I carried on drinking I had to
be taken okay see ya and then I had to
be taken home and then and then from
then on we just started hanging out
and so burner slow burner slow burner
and then we were I was just thought we
were walking down the road and I thought
[ __ ] it I mean if it's gonna happen it's
gonna you know I've got to try something
so I leaned in I just told ya you had to
be bold at something yeah and you just
went for it now if she'd have said
excuse me what are you doing I would
have been like that makes sense it's
carry on walking but you know how many
guys wouldn't have done that they just
carried on and on and maybe they were
thought oh you know what I'll do it but
I'm really sure she likes me and they
wait and wait so many guys have waited
waited waited and it's been like month
two months and then she's found someone
else in the meantime or she'll be like
oh I actually because you never you know
approach you never did anything I just
presumed you didn't like me well they
just start seeing you as just that
eternal friend so you did a bold move
that's good but you had time to play
with her because you know you kept
giving her this spot that's good you're
using resources to say me to like that's
what people do women use their looks to
lure guys into dates you know we use our
looks right well this is I was going to
ask you but I'm curious what you make of
feminism in in the current in the car do
you consider are you a feminist yourself
I'm a single mom I take no money from my
ex-partner who's a multi
multi-millionaire okay so he doesn't pay
any child maintenance I run my own
company left school at 15 I've never
I've been out with very wealthy men
never relied on them for money or
anything never been sponsored by anyone
so I don't know is that is that sounds
like a feminist to me that does sound
like a feminist without preaching to
other people so when people say are you
favored tonight but I'm kind of living
that life of a feminist I'm just not
preaching about it to other people
you're a bad feminist no but that's my
joke no you know
but this but I guess so what's a bad
feminist then well I was only joking you
know I don't get offended by anything
anyway if you mentioned my weight or
anything my question my joke was more
based around the fact that a lot of
these feminism or and other movements
they seem to be about preaching rather
than living this is exactly the pilot
you're making yeah so I actually think
someone like Hughes is it good I'll give
you what happened okay so I put
something on social media which is it
was International Women's Day which I
think it's just I just get I think it's
cringe and I think international man's
day is cringe and International anything
day is a bit cringe not all of it but
the man and woman day is a bit cringe
because I was watching this thing I'm
fold on social media of international
Woman's Day and it was like there's a
lot of cupcakes and things involved like
a lot of people posting cupcakes and
stuff I was like and I said I'm sorry I
just don't agree with this whole
International Women's Day and oh my god
the backlash I had from the feminist
movement I don't know who these people
were a lot of them had blue hair and
they targeted me on Facebook I didn't
know what they're up against because
I've got like all these followers or
just you know these people I was like no
no I'm gonna respond pop please do it so
they started calling me a penis Pandora
I'm just playin I'm a penis Pandora
hashtag penis Pandora never heard of
this one before they said you're just
pandering through the penis the way you
dress you are
hashtag part of the problem all this and
I wrote a great response and first of
all I made sure that I was in a very
provocative kind of penis Pandora
position you know my my bikini on
looking really like inaudible and things
and I put on there like a message saying
yeah maybe I'm a penis planner maybe I
love men attention I do I really like
men attention but also I am a single mom
I'm also somebody who thinks feminism is
essentially a good thing so why do we
have to like classify what's this
identity politics all of a sudden why
can't we be many things and that
since like my left wing right wing you
know like there's lots of different
aspects of both that I agree with my I
don't agree with and it comes down to
this so I wrote this message saying you
know in my life there's a lot of guys
who have kind of you know fallen out
with because they've underestimated me
or whatever they've said when I'm angry
that I'm hysterical the kind of usual
stuff that women moan about guys but
it's like the people who have actually
really held me back have been women in
my life my own personal experience it's
like women haven't given me the leg up
at all they'll help me I found that men
have been better allies to me and women
but anyway put this response so and
actually it went a little bit viral a
little bit more a lot of people so
reposting going this is real feminism
what she's doing by herself all this
this is real feminism and that was from
both men and women that's why I made the
joke that you're a bad feminist because
actually I think someone who does that
they are a good feminist and it's the
people running for it
shutting down everyone else and and like
you say it's fascinating that you bring
up identity politics because this is
something we talk about all the time
okay and this is exactly where we are
coming from which is the simple
understanding that people are much more
complex than these simple categories
that they get thrown into but the reason
I brought up the feminist issue in the
first place is you were talking about
using looks to get attention and stuff
like that and there seems to be some
people now who just say no you know this
doesn't exist men and women aren't using
their looks for different things of men
on using status to get female attention
and all this chaos right but they are
right I hope you should actually yeah I
think if a man has game then it doesn't
matter if he loses all his wealth and
his you know accolades he will still get
women I hope that's why I teach guys I
teach guys game I teach them how to be
attracted to women no matter what the
circumstances are so you say the one
game what does game actually mean okay
I'm game just to be good with women the
skills that we had a famous
he's not super famous he's in a soap
opera in England and he obviously
because he's famous is like goes out
gets women it's super easy and he's like
he came to us with him you don't need
any help
yeah but I want to be able to learn how
to attract women when I'm in another
country and also you I know this is not
going to last right and you know the ex
soap opera because we've had loads of
like ex soap opera - not bad right yeah
I could see women have something else
women lose their looks whereas guys you
know if they lose their thing that is
usually a career as money or something
like that that's when they fall to
pieces so he came to us and he said he's
gonna go to South America for like a
month and he just wants now to poor
women because he won't be able to rely
on his status at all so that's what we
teach I don't think I should rely I
don't think women should rely it like
I've started losing my looks recently I
know I'm so but I've noticed it's a bill
thing I've noticed I'm like well I've
got to just work much harder on getting
richer by people and just like work on
my personality it's just like that's it
I have to work on my game now my looks
are fading and so with guys I just think
don't don't rely on the accolades and
the success because that can go tomorrow
rely on your game and do you think we've
started and it's become I've seen it
grow more and more and especially you
because I used to be a teacher in
schools is a victim culture have you
seen the victim culture creep into men
and you know essentially blame everybody
else apart from themselves yeah yeah so
it's the red have you heard of the red
pill movie yes I had Coach red pill he's
very smart guy I had him on my my
podcast and he had me on his show and
basically the red pill movement the guys
and mid-tower which has men going their
own way movement they don't like women
in general and they don't like me so
when I went on his show the hate I got
was worse than the hate I got from the
feminists or like she's a calm bucket
you know that's all she's good
for she looks like like a blow-up doll
all this color stuff she's fake hope she
gets AIDS soon really we do I mean it
doesn't bother me at all there's no
mention my weight no but really it
doesn't hurt because when your because
I've been in this movement I've been in
this industry for so long you should see
what some of the old forums used to say
about these two pictures of us and all
sorts of [ __ ] so you're kind of Numb to
it you don't care anymore anyway sorry
to digress he I went on his show and he
put a video up saying never take advice
from a woman and then he did something
quite controversial and put me on his
show asking me a question so I was like
you know what come on my podcast see
what happens and he came on and I
challenged him just as he challenged me
and I said to him you know I've looked
at the guys that you're teaching and
you're right you know there's there's a
lot for them to be pissed off about with
women and the me to movement and you
know I get it there's frustration there
but at some point you've got to say
there's nothing I can do about this mmm
there's nothing I can do this is an
external issue here I have to just work
on myself because what's happening is
they're like go [ __ ] women yeah [ __ ]
women they're like you know they're
being they're becoming is it in sell so
they become virgins yes and like that's
that's dumb that's done because you're
just gonna be more more bitter yeah it's
true what red pillar movement is there's
so much truth in it I'm not gonna lie
this is quite controversial me saying
but there's so much truth in it like how
the dating balance is completely skewed
and favor for women and how men are
being encouraged to be more more beta by
society this is [ __ ] this is terrible
and they have a right to be [ __ ]
angry about it but play the game play
the game so when students come to me and
like oh but women expect this and that
might play the game play the game well
couldn't work on your skills and you
will cut through this because women are
fundamentally still attracted to the
same things that they always have been
yeah yeah which is a man who has a
strong sense of character a strong
reality who's unapologetic for who he is
that doesn't mean in an arrogant way but
it's not someone who's trying to
apologize
everything that they do someone who is
comfortable with himself and who is
unapologetic about and and almost honest
about his own personal trajectory in
life it's very important and the choices
that he's made he's fascinating to me
that you say that because sometimes my
wife and I we have like she wants me to
do something and I'm like no I'm not
doing that and she's like no no I really
want to do I'm like no I'm not doing
that like what I don't have a dog but it
might it's something that I am entitled
not to do if I don't want to it's not
like an obligation that I actually
sexual thing
no I was gonna make that joke can I hope
well done Casey no it's literally like
kid can you go there and pick this thing
up instead of me because I forgot
something like that okay
whatever and if I can like consistently
refused to do something that I don't
want to do for whatever it might be like
she's got some new vitamins that she
wants me to try let's say that right
she's okay well you need to you need to
take these vitamins these animal and I
don't want to
okay she's like no you've got to I'm
like no I'm not doing it and she's like
no no you really have to I'm like no and
after a while she'll go away and then
two minutes later she comes back and she
she'll go you know what I really loved
the way you really know like what you
stand for yeah that's cool she's
qualifying you by the way which is cause
she's to be regaining the PZ a little
trick actually that I teach guys to you
how does she qualify me is it the fact
that she comes back and acknowledges the
fact that I've stood up for whatever but
by doing that she's taking the power
back as oh yeah she's qualified she's
validated your behavior right so I call
this the diffusion technique is actually
doesn't diffuse but I wrote that in my
book it's called the diffusion technique
and this or stuck with now it's actually
called the negative attraction technique
so a lot of guys would be like I don't
want to get into a really serious topic
with a woman because we might end up
arguing it starts becoming heated and
then you know she's lose interest and
like no no keep that going it's good if
it's heated okay get to invest some
passion into the conversation even if
it's negative and then shift that into a
positive
g'bye say get the book just say to her
look you know what let's this stop me
and you and never gonna agree on this
right she goes right so she's on the yes
letter now we could sit here and argue
about this all week and we still
wouldn't agree about it right she's
right you know what that's what I
actually really like about you you don't
back down
don't you think other people they just
agree and just sort of like bend their
own reality in accordance with someone
else's just not their head and you like
me you just you'll stick to your guns I
love it so what you're trying to say
there is we are both passionate people
and everyone else is like not passionate
so that's a way of flipping it around
and creating attraction out you're my
wife's got game
she knows though she does but she wasn't
doing it to create attraction and this
you like had Angry sex after information
but what she was doing it she was like
thinking like I can't win this battle so
I'm gonna kind of like win the war you
show that I am I mean she's just using a
tactic to say I like that about you you
hunt you in the head I like but but I
think it also comes back to your point
which is that women do like a man who
stands up for what he believes who has a
strong sense of reality and again two
guys out there never bend your own
realities in accordance with the girls
ever she's very aware of it she'll say
something the guy would be you know
shifting his opinion she's very aware of
it like oh god he's turning into the
head nod did the one that agrees of
everything she says but it's a great
point that you make because you can tell
when somebody's being fake you just can
and it just becomes this interesting if
someone just goes oh this is what I
think these are the reason is well I
think if you don't know it that's fine
but this is where I am automatically you
have an emotional reaction to it it
means that you're more comfortable with
who you are and it's showing that that's
what it's conveying is that you're
comfortable with who you are in your
piñas and you've brought them out it's
just little things like that just make
someone more attractive absolutely let's
talk about some let's talk about the
difference between boys and girls
because I'm
you've got a little boy and I used to be
a teacher so right away from full 218
and people go there's no difference
between the genders huge difference it's
a lot of crack huge so let's get into it
so when I had my son I was like totally
like those people thinking oh I know I
think that if you just keep giving toy
cars to boys and action man to boys you
know they're gonna end up being more
aggressive and if you keep giving dolls
to little girls you know they're gonna
be more maternal now I just let my son
have wherever he wanted I can want a
doll have a doll just points hurt you
have it you know when I go out with you
I'm like Richard Gere you know and at
first when they're really young they
really will play very old shirt it is
gender neutral the toys but then you
start getting to a point where two years
old I notice that's the shift the boys
start wanting to play with other boys
before that they don't care the girls
want to play with other girls at nursery
the boys are playing I hope this is
gonna offend so many women fantastic
boys do want to build things and destroy
they want to make they they like the
Lego and the bricks more than the girls
there are the exception to the rules
there are the little girls who love
building I know God bless them and
there's a little boys who really hate
all that and love brushing you know the
dolls hair again it's exception to the
rule the boys were immediately the cause
and even the the nursery workers were
like we have to hide the cars from the
boys because they just zoom into the
cars God knows why I still can't work
out what the thing is about the wheels
going around or something what it is but
we were girls just didn't want to play
the cause and the boys wanted to build
things and then they wanted to smash it
all up
where are they learning this it wasn't
for me it wasn't am I speak to that and
I had a conversation of parent school I
found this is so fascinating so I spoke
to the other moms of the boys I'm like
where did they learn this like we're not
smashing stuff up
we're like you we brought them up not
gender neutral but we've kind of like no
aim to make them like tough boys at all
and they end up like that so now he's at
school and when you when they're like
school gates open
the boys just go in there and they're
making this kind of very prime noise
when they're going in I'm not going to
do it's really unattractive noise noise
all of them inflate they're just going
in there and they just want to destroy
the whole school and the girls are just
standing there like is this madness
I'm a West Ham fan I'll get to see it
every week that primal or but I couldn't
do it you know you you mentioned no
getting away from this but this is not
me I wish I could come and tell you
something else
this is my experience I have never tried
to make my boiler go out and you know
come on champ I don't use things like
that I just bring them up like whatever
you know just be a nice person and do
what you want well exactly and it's
funny that you mentioned that you
noticed it at a particular time because
actually the research there's a guy call
he's actually Sacha Baron Cohen's cousin
a brother or something their relatives
who does research on this and they did
research with day old infants so they're
literally the moment they're born Wow
they offer them a toy that's either like
an object like a truck or something or
like a piece of wood or whatever or like
an anthropomorphic like a human shaped
doll or something and even at that age
one day all the girls reach for the the
human shape it's the same with monkeys
you do the same extensive research yeah
yes I think you've got to do a lot of
yeah well it's the same with monkeys as
well we do the same experiment with
monkeys female monkeys are more likely
to reach for that and the kind of monkey
shaped thing male monkeys are more
likely to reach for the stick or
whatever it might be well as evolution
is evolution men evolved to manipulate
objects to hunt to-do-list
anticipate rock it's ingrained in order
yeah I mean yeah when they're in the
mood with all this patriarchal [ __ ]
toxic I knew I was having a boy maybe he
sensed it yeah yeah I better live up to
that boy kind of image but it's also do
you think that nowadays as men like we
have to sort of deny our masculinity a
little bit you do you shouldn't but
that's what society is trying to do to
you guys and it's could you go into that
a little bit more
why they're doing it because they want
to empower women by putting men down and
I don't think it needs that that should
happen I don't think that I don't think
you need to do that in order to empower
women I feel very empowered I've always
felt very empowered I've never I've
never looked at men as my superiors or
inferior x' i've looked at them as my
equals not this you know i don't get
with these i mean okay this women have
had terrible experiences with men I have
to actually I had a relationship with
violent guy was violent to me so I've
had my fair share it doesn't mean I go
and say every single man's violent that
was a bad relationship but I've always
seen men as my equals and I think that's
that's a good thing to thing and I don't
know why we have to make men into our
subordinates with what society is trying
to do it's like if that's the way to
raise women to empower women by
denigrating men yes I've noticed in the
adverts a lot why the men always looking
so stupid in adverts incompetent okay
men are a little bit more incompetent
with small children than women I've
noticed that not all so I'm not saying
they're bad fathers but there's just
little details I found men sort of
terrible impressed I don't know I don't
think I think women maybe are on the
whole a little bit more what's the word
forgotten paying more attention to
detail when it comes to yeah very small
children but it's also because I think
part of this is like so for instance
early years teachers are always women
are always women I remember and there
was this drive to try and get men but
it's less so by the way my son he had a
male one he was the best one that he had
you see it's changing which is good
nobody knows good I think men you know
becoming nurses and looking after
children's a good thing I don't think
that that's the part that's belittling
men I think it's when women are treating
men badly and laughing at men and
humiliating men on adverts and on TV
that becomes an issue and this is where
we come back to what you were saying
earlier that makes my face it's not me
going mad I you see this
when they make fun about men looking off
the baby so there was an advert recently
where the men left their children in the
buggy
because though it was for Philadelphia
cheese or something and it was this
whole big awkward I was like that's not
a bad thing actually it's like we all
know that men are not so good with small
babies as as the moms are they pay less
attention to detail so I was like that's
not the issue because men it's more like
when the woman is kind of like making
the man look stupid in every day-to-day
life that I think is the issue other
than things that have always been there
that make sense absolutely makes
absolute perfect sense and and what I
was going to say is it takes us back to
what you were saying a little bit
earlier which is that there is a group
of men now who have become resentful
bitter or resigned who've disconnected
from society of disconnected from dating
and as you say I mean you could argue
they have some legitimate concerns where
my feeling on it is they need more game
I've always thought this about any part
of your life wherever you're not happy
about something your careers and going
as well as you want it to be you're not
getting you know as comedians you're not
getting to the play the club so you want
to play you're not getting to where you
want to get to you've got to get better
you know and and every part of life is
it's on your shoulders get better get
better right but with this it's now
starting to say you know it's like just
give up yes but do you okay what's your
thoughts of this I I don't like the
internet dating I don't like I know
people have found happiness from it I
don't do it and I I think it's okay as
an option but it shouldn't be the only
solution to finding someone if a guy
doesn't look good how is he going to
meet anyone from online dating if he
can't have a good picture of himself
what if he's like disfigured hmm like
he's been in a terrible accident and
he's disfigured who is going to click on
his photograph go yeah I'll meet you
it's just not gonna okay you you might
get some people but it's gonna be very
very rare okay it's it's this is just
it's sad it's by being honest it's not
like a fetish out there for disfigured
people I mean it's like a fat person I
should say overweight person that was
politically correct we are called
trigonometry system but people who can't
stop easy okay Bob kids came out like a
big woman in somewhere like like a big
guy but someone is disfigured or look
really bad okay physically just bad
they haven't been blessed of looks then
just not they're just gonna be swiped
yeah there's gonna be swiped and yet
that guy could have amazing game amazing
chat he could be so funny and because he
his only way to meet women has now
become through dating apps because of
hashtag me to which has tried it's best
to frighten men into not approaching
women if that's his only way of meeting
women he's [ __ ] hmm
he is [ __ ] because what you really
teach from talking about you is your of
connection it's getting some old
disfigured
we had a guy sorry for interrupting on
we had a guy who was in a wheelchair
okay he came to us in this wheelchair
and it was through it wasn't an accident
it but he used to be able to walk it was
a medical condition and he had this
wheelchair but it was like built in a
certain way where he was like raised
quite high and he's like I want people
to see beyond the wheelchair I'm like no
one's gonna see beyond the wheelchair
it's there okay it's not like you know
my like you've got like a pimple or
something you've got this huge
wheelchair he's like yeah yeah but you
know I've I wanna get my personality
through I'm like okay the wheelchair is
your prop you talk about it you you talk
about the elephant in the room here okay
you make it work it's part of your act
just like you guys do what the routine
and so one of our guys is very good at
one-liners he turned around and said
look you've just got to go up to him and
say I suppose you're wondering why I'm
in this wheelchair and then the woman's
like really thinking yes I would like to
know but she didn't want to ask
obviously it's like it's because I got
this enormous penis now God feminists
and hashtag me too you know
people be like oh my god you can't say
something like this okay
okay the girl knows every girl that he
used that line with burst out laughing
she could see he was a funny guy so you
know you're looking at this is a funny
person not someone in a wheelchair so
when all these people go you shouldn't
say things like they shouldn't talk
about your penis like this what should
he have done what you've done what's a
better solution well he should have just
been himself people can't see beyond the
wheelchair unless he shows that he's got
this funny that's his funny side that's
his humor do you see what I mean no I'm
sorry so there's this great area
everything for them is very black and
white yeah you know you mentioned the
word penis it's harassment it was it was
that really harassment that example I
just gave you it was it was just like it
was it was a joke so that's what I mean
like if this guy had just used dating
apps which he was going down that that
route and he's like I'll just you know
I'll just use my face and take away the
world Joe might be she's gonna see you
and it's gonna be awkward it's like okay
I take the photograph of my wheelchair
then I was like okay you're gonna get
less people wanting to see I'm sorry I
it's a harsh world out there that's the
reality but you see what I mean so he
now knows how to talk to women because
of us but what's happening is they're
trying to I don't think they're not
purposely trying to force it but what's
happening is loads of people are just
saying you know what let's just use
dating apps it's easy and no one can do
me for harassment of dating apps but
then it's a massive letdown because you
go meet this person they're nothing like
their pictures this is why I don't use
dating apps by the way because there's
been so many times I've been in a bar
and a guy's walked in not my type not my
physical type it's just the way he moves
something he says some behavioral
trigger I don't know what it was it just
made me go hmm that's interesting I
would never get that from a one
dimensional photograph no absolutely and
we're talking about jokes now and
negging is a big thing and I see a lot
of guys doing that
negging where do you stand on it do you
agree with it because sometimes I'll see
a blog doing it and I'm like a [ __ ]
yeah you got to do it properly so if
you're being you know if you say to a
woman something like I'll try to think
of like I don't really teach negging I
use double-sided compliments rather than
their game because nothing can come
across like
insult mm-hmm but noise we were just
like exactly you're being a jerk so I
use double-sided compliments like I'll
say to a guy say to a woman like you
know you look great use a very vague
compliment and then add on a detailed
suggestion of how she can look even
better so you know you look great this
is actually not a joke
so I'm sort of it's not comical but it's
kind of like it's a spinoff from nagging
you say you know you look great but you
know what if you were wearing and I'm
sorry
I love stripper high heels like those
really tacky plastic was I'd be making a
move on you now and something like that
actually says to the girl you are
sexually escalating with her but you're
not hmm you say unit nice and at heart
so you sort of cushioning the blow want
to be there when you say that you like
it most guys don't I found but some guys
are like like girls wearing those tacky
Hills I shouldn't say it because it'll
make me look like it is a fetish and
I've got really bad taste like no no no
own it do you remember that Chris Rock
yes carry heels yeah what do I get
another one which is when guys want to
do anal no it's like it's like the nice
guys like oh please please can I do it
please something like there's like
something that he said that other guys
just like totally unapologetic for what
he wants what it turns him on I don't
think was oh no I think it was something
a little bit more personal but he was
just totally he's like beyond apologetic
about it that's your thing that's what
you want and the guys that's kind of
like unsure and uncertain about showing
what his desire is you know what his
fetish is that's gonna then look creepy
yeah though such a real thing is creepy
it's basically if you come across
uncertain ashamed or embarrassed by what
turns you on that will come across as
creepy the guy that's like this is why
I'm in to take or leave it the girl
might say he's too bold that's a bit too
confident but she won't say creepy
that's
a guy's biggest fears being a creep it's
the biggest fear all our students say
that it's bigger than rejection it's
like okay I can handle rejection but not
if she's rejecting me because I'm creepy
dude that's got worse than the age of
social media where someone can go all
this creepy guy you know whatever else
in no I haven't seen that I haven't seen
any evidence of that how that's
interesting because I want to thought
that we were the age of you know
reputation online reputation that made
me be more worried about it I have
honestly I have I've been very honest
throughout this whole you know I can't
tell you if I've noticed no I think this
might be a yeah it's just but but you're
right I think that is and but it's
interesting like I'm just processing
some of the examples here you're giving
an employee and admittedly I don't go
out and try and meet women but I just
it sounds very kind of non 2019 if you
know what I mean
and I wonder what what you make of this
like I mean for example actually the
question I was going to ask you is about
these people who are in sales or who are
part of this men going their own way
thing you presumably your advice to them
would be to up their game right and to
get better and to go out there and learn
how to meet people the opposite sex they
don't even yeah it's it hasn't the level
of game that we were teaching in 2006
hasn't evolved because it's essentially
still it's the same principles that's
interesting so it's the same principles
nothing has really changed because know
deep down with the only thing you've got
is you've got less competition now guys
because all the other guys are on
scrolling through apps our students are
cleaning up right now they are cleaning
up time to end a relationship
I've got no game I'm terrible with men
that's why I don't teach women you don't
use women to put this [ __ ] easy but
you know if you're a good-looking woman
you don't need oh come on you don't you
just walk in everyone's like yeah no
great know what okay so I take students
into strip clubs to prove this to them
love strip clubs and I take them to this
particular one I said which woman do you
think is doing really well here and he
always picked her like the five foot ten
blonde you know the most striking
beautiful woman in the room I'm like
look at her cuz they put their money in
this heavenly money and they put their
money in a garter look by the end of the
night who's got more money in that one
or that one and I'll point to a girl
whose plane really like Plain Jane and
then I all right fine you're on I said
I'm watch them work the room now guys
may go to strip clubs they're there to
see tits and you know that's it it's
just it's purely aesthetics that's why
they're in their case visual and yet the
plain girl will make most of money you
know why because she has game the other
was relying on her looks so she will get
the initial dancers guys are gonna say I
want that one you know and she'll do her
dances and she's got no chat boring as
[ __ ] and in this this other girl has had
to rely on her game and her banter and
her wit and that sheer ambition that
desire okay and that she's coming from a
very positive place the other one very
positive like I'm gonna I'm gonna kill
it tonight I am gonna clean up tonight
and all this combined makes her almost
like a machine this girl I think the
guys like had his three dancers when she
approached her he's like how do you want
she's not even that hard like what do
you want you can see that's the initial
hmm that that's her initial the reaction
that she experiences is she just plows
plows and suddenly it's like the guys
just spending all his money and like
watch this is guys who are only
interested opposed idli in look and that
go is running rings around the
good-looking go that's the power of game
if a woman's if a woman can imagine what
a man can do because women are less
visual bother me but even me I've got my
limit where I'm like okay he's just
pouring I can't find see this guy even
if he's really hot so I take them to the
strip club when they and then only when
they see this happening did they get it
they're like yeah it's all game well the
appeal of your courses goes up and up
and up as we get more detail
you know one our infamous mentioning
that it has been one hour because our
last question I think thank you for the
interview we were really enjoyed it our
last question is always the same which
is what is the one thing that no one is
talking about that we should be talking
I've got to choose a cake
it's either scrolling through phones ok
people really need to talk about how
smartphones are the source of all evil
okay this needs to be addressed not
internet smartphones well we can talk
about cats and dogs you pick let's go
some are fast yeah that's too small cats
and dogs ok so you see this whole thing
about anxiety and depression it's coming
out I'm really kind of I don't know
about this I'm I'm in to two minds about
this one because I think a lot of
anxiety and stuff is coming from those
[ __ ] phones I'm just like put away
your phone look up smell the roses enjoy
life you know and you will be less
anxious and you'll be less depressed and
you will be human again and you won't be
like some walking zombie I just don't
think it's been talked about enough
I think everyone's that everyone's just
kind of so lost in this phone just
walking around like this and I see
people with their dogs this is really
sad people with their kids it's even
worse the people they're walking their
dogs and the dogs sitting there and they
look at their phone and dogs got the
ball in his mouth waiting for you to
throw the ball and you were just on your
phone and I see that cuz I have a dog so
I walk my dog a lot of time and and I
never look at that phone I really don't
and this it's like I've got to do
something and I just see people not
talking to each other people in
restaurants on their phone people
ignoring their dogs ignoring their
children just looking at their phone and
I just think this this is this is the
breakdown this is it it's not the
internet it's not social media is having
acts I have social we do bi have no
social media on my photo from Instagram
which someone else looks after I have no
social media apps in that phone I can
live without I can go home log on when I
have to update or check something
remember the old days used to log on on
your computer and it was like it was it
was finite you know
all right our lair go go to another room
now or something right
when is that it you know infinite kind
of information entertainment that access
to it I think that's a growing Society
you did manage to get the dogs in there
in answer really strongly about this and
I did a whole episode on it it's just
this look at it look at when you go out
look at the restaurants look at
teenagers not talking to each other I
used to love meeting my friends when I
was like 12 that's like the happiest
point of our lives you know 10 12 I'm
seeing my friend you know I can talk I
can play them and it's when the parents
can kind of say you know what you're old
enough now where I don't need to
entertain you you can entertain each
other first thing they do is give them
phones and they're sitting there in
silence I see it all the time and if I
do say on my phone I actually say to my
son I'm gonna be on it for two minutes
I'm gonna ignore you for two minutes
I've got to finish this text or
something and he knows I don't just sit
there in this kind of like vortex of
scrolling see all the time and I think
it's causing anxiety depression it's
breaking down our social communication
the way we feel just everything a little
bit's been poisoned with these
smartphones I totally agree it's a
really good point let me ask you a bonus
question actually because we've had
loads of guests talking about it so we
oh sorry I don't mean it in that way
several people mentioned that it's
important and we couldn't agree more and
I'm like listen guys I don't say about
it I don't use the phone so you can do
it too you can do it don't use the phone
just it's only in emergencies the
question I was gonna ask you I was dared
amber festival for the whole month this
year and another comedian had a dog
there since you brought up the subject
of dogs that she needed walked while she
was doing a show in a couple of times I
took the dog I did not realize how much
of a [ __ ] magnet' met a dog it's more
effective than Aston Martin we did the
test so my friend has nestin Martin and
he was like going around I was in the
corners like all the girls were looking
at him and then I say what's this little
guy coming along
down the street he's got what was a
French Bulldog I was like what all the
eyes go on him and just click away from
you the Aston Martin do its jobs James
Bond's car it's fine and he just didn't
exist anymore it was that dog I need my
dad sometimes my friends borrow my dog
can I just buy your dog LeBron I like go
to a bar pub or something they have the
dog on their lap and just like all these
girls around say you know talk about the
dog and I just think guys need to
capitalize on that I teach guys to get a
dog approach with me when you're walking
your dog and they're walking their dog
it's a great way to meet women there you
go if you're an insult get a dog yeah on
that happy note we will see you in a
week from now and goodbye thank you see
you later guys thanks for watching guys
as always subscribe to the youtube
channel click the bell button next to
subscribe button so you get notified
when a video comes out and follow us on
all the social media at trigger pod and
also leave us a nice review on iTunes
and spread the word